My name is Kylie Kristen Jenner.
I'm 23 years old.
My favorite color is pink.
I was 17 when I launched Kylie Cosmetics.
It feels weird that this is my life now.
Looking back at it though, makeup has just been a part of my DNA.
When I was younger, I had an insecurity with my lips.
I would go to makeup stores at the mall...
...and just find like lip liner that matched my lip color...
...and just would overline my lips.
I became obsessed with makeup in general.
I just never found like a lip liner or lipstick that matched...
...so I really wanted to make a lip kit...
...where your lip liner and your lipstick they match, they're in a kit,...
...it's easy for people.
And when I first launched my lip kit,...
...I took a picture and posted it on Instagram before it launched.
We all got on the website at the same time and it wouldn't load.
And I thought the site crashed.
Something was really wrong with the platform.
Oh my goodness! This whole thing has just crashed.
And then I get a phone call and they said:...
"Oh no, we sold out of everything in less than a minute."
Kylie Jenner released her lipstick at 9 a.m this morning...
...and the kits sold out in just a matter of minutes.
She just announced it on social media, "My lip kits are up."
And within seconds, it was gone.
And I was like, "What?"
We should have ordered more lip kits. Oh no!
It started off as Lip Kit by Kylie...
...then when I realized after the first launch...
...that it could be something that I've always dreamed about,...
...a real cosmetics line, then I changed it to Kylie Cosmetics.